voilà nouvelle chronique on vous propose
de découvrir aujourd'hui vu de russie
présenté par elena volochine bonjour l
énergie la correspondante à moscou ces
dix dernières années à nos côtés par
mean donc aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser
à ce que raconte puisque on décrypte la
communication des deux ukrainiens avec
ses prises de paroles de vos lumières et
les ssii à ce que raconte avec vous la
télévision et la propagande russe et à
comment la guerre en ukraine et vu
depuis la russie aujourd'hui oui
effectivement et c'est très important on
va regarder ensemble le journal de la
première chaîne de télévision russe
pervyi kanal vous vous souvenez c'est ce
journal ou a fait irruption le 14 mars
dernier marina officielle ni cobas et
rédactrice qui est venu avec sa pancarte
vous la voyez maintenant dire non à la
guerre elle disait aussi sur cette
pancarte ne croyait pas à la propagande
on vous ment alors on s'est intéressés
justement à ce que raconte ce journal
télévisé de la première chaîne russe
j'ai regardé pour vous l'édition du jt
de prime times d'hier soir voici les
titres
gasp au robinet genouilly l'histoire
dramatique du sauvetage des habitants de
la vengeance des forces du craignait
c'est notre équipe de tournage à
partager une voiture avec des réfugiés
à léopold et airolo dia marioupol et ces
gens dès que les bombardements des
ukrainiens se taisent ils sortent des
caf pour continuer à vivre les images
les plus fréquents
pas de droit à l'erreur c'est nos héros
artir sur des complexes beaux ils
risquent leur vie ils ont couvert leurs
camarades des tirs de l'aviation et
craignaient ils ont abattu les cibles
aériennes jusqu'à la dernier
alors dans ces titres vous avez cette
construction classique est essentiel du
narratif russe de ce conflit donc on a
trois titres le premier il nous dit que
il parle de vengeance des forces du
craignait non nous montre les images de
roubaix genouillères ou beige noyer
c'est en république populaire dite de
lougansk donc l'un de ces deux
territoires séparatistes qui a été
repris avec l'aide des russes à
l'ukraine en 2014 et c'est la seule le
seul côté du conflit que montre la
télévision de russe depuis le début
c'est le côté qui est donc en guerre
avec l'ukraine et ou par par la force
des choses et bien atterrissent les obus
ukrainien il parle bien de vengeance un
des forces du craignent haine contre ses
populations russophones donc toujours ce
fameux mythe de dd nazis ukrainien qui
se venge ensuite deuxième titre
marioupol ça ça fait la une chez nous
également mais là on nous dit dès que
les bombardements ukrainiens se taisent
donc selon la propagande russe ce sont
les ukrainiens qui m'ont board mario
poste jamais les russes les russes ils
sont là pour aider les civils et le
troisième titre on nous montre
finalement cette armée russe à la pointe
de la technologie qui et qui fait preuve
de fratrie au combat qui est prête à
risquer sa vie c'est armées russes pour
sauver les camarades en danger et qu'il
ne rate jamais ses cibles et des cibles
qui sont toujours donc des cibles
militaires jamais des cibles civiles
alors je disais une grosse passe de ce
journal de la première chaîne russe est
dédié à marioupol et comme on le disait
marioupol serait selon l'adb russe
bombardée par les nationalistes
ukrainiens que la propagande russe
assimile aux nazis écouter
marioupol en république populaire de
dounia est encore un point sur la carte
du dombass sous les unités nationaliste
de l'ukraine tirs à l'armés aux mortiers
sur des quartiers habités ou chaque
moment de silence offre la possibilité
de sortir de la cave pour aller chercher
de l'aide humanitaire distribué par
l'adn air et la russie les corridors
humanitaires dans notre direction sont
l'unique chance de sacha se passer voilà
des corridors humanitaires mise en place
par les russes qui serait l'unique
chance de salut pour les ukrainiens
bombardé par par les nazis voilà donc ce
que nous dit la propagande et on
souligne aussi que dans cet extrait
marioupol se situe selon le présentateur
en république populaire de n'y est qu'un
et non pas en ukraine donc dans ce
territoire séparatiste donc on fait fi
du droit international au passage et
dans une autre dans un autre moment de
ce journal est bien la télévision russe
affirme aussi que ce que les ukrainiens
refusent absolument de mettre en place
tout corridor humanitaire alors c'est un
on est totalement à l'opposé de ce que
l'on diffuse évidemment dans nos
journaux à nous dans tout ce qu'ils
diffusent l'occident aujourd'hui
notamment absents de ces images l'armée
russe alors on voit l'armée russe et
l'armée russe justement fait deux points
quotidiens avec le général notamment
connaissent une coiffe le porte parole
de l'armée russe qui qui qui explique
les actions mais on ne montre jamais les
destructions liées à l'armée russe vous
voyez sur ces images qu'on voit en ce
moment on nous montre toujours des
images satellites de frappe ultra ciblé
d'objectifs militaires seulement la
rhétorique aussi est importante on
utilise des armes de pointe à guidage
donc toujours on cible des objectifs
militaires qui sont situés seulement
dans la forêt jamais dans les zones
habitées voilà donc ce genre d'image
seulement que voient les russes de ski
pour ce qui est en tout cas des
bombardements russes et donc on passe
maintenant sur la chaîne de télévision
en continu
d'informations en continu de télévision
d'état rossiya-24 et là j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur ces bandes
annonces qui tourne entre les journaux
c'est très important elles ont leur
importance il s'agit par exemple pour
celle que vous voyez en ce moment de
dire que les américains auraient des
laboratoires secrets de fabrication
d'armes biologiques en ukraine ça c'est
un leit motiv en ce moment
2pour pour pour dire que soi-disant les
etats-unis menacent avec des armes
biologiques
la russie finalement le monde entier
avec des armes biologiques qui
fabriquerait en ukraine il montre aussi
des bandes annonces de
l'expansion de l'otan donc on va voir
peut-être cette bande annonce avec de
plus en plus de pays qui qui ont intégré
l'otan depuis 1997 c'est une exigence de
vladimir poutine que l'otan retire ses
troupes et voyez d'ailleurs au tout
début de la bande annonce vous avez vu
le même le format de cette bande annonce
il ya ce fameux z1 qu'il est le symbole
de l'intervention des troupes russes
donc même la symbolique est reprise par
par la télévision russe
et aussi à 24 elle nous parle elle
carrément donc de néo-nazis ukrainien je
vous propose d'écouter
plus de quatre millions et demi
d'habitants pacifique demeure les otages
des néonazis ukrainiens notamment à
kharkiv cherni vaisseau c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le chef du centre national de
direction de l'auto défense le général
lieutenant mireille limousine sec les
civils sont toujours utilisés comme
boucliers humains le général lieutenant
a précisé qu'il n'y avait pas parmi eux
que les citoyens ukrainiens mais aussi
des étrangers issus de 25 pays c'est un
point intéressant elena la légende des
étrangers qui qui combattrait
aujourd'hui en ukraine oui effectivement
c'est un leit motiv de la télévision
russe qui en plus donc de glorifier les
actions de l'armée russe a pour but de
dénigrer celle de l'armée ukrainienne et
notamment il y à aussi tous eu toute
cette rhétorique cette construction
narrative autour des mercenaires
étrangers toujours quelque part aussi
pour faire miroiter le spectre de
l'occident ennemis et l'a carrément la
télévision russe n'hésitent pas à
fabriquer des fake par exemple vous
allez voir que france 24 est cité dans
l'un de ses reportages
la chaîne france 24 a publié un sujet
sur les mercenaires étrangers dans ce
reportage les légionnaires qui allait
partir sur la ligne de front doute de
leur décision l'ong greenpeace voulait
des satanistes convergent vers l'ukraine
au sein de la compagnie militaire privée
qui s'appelle je traduis le groupe d
observation de ligne de front des ex des
forces spéciales américaines qui prêtent
allégeance au diable au sens propre ils
ont un drapeau avec une symbolique
éloquente le canoë
selon les experts il renvoie aux crimes
des américains en afghanistan lorsque
d'un seul tir il brise le crâne de
l'ennemi blessés andes
alors là si vous n'avez rien compris à
ce qu'a dit le présentateur c'est normal
c'est l'un des buts de cette propagande
distillée comme ça des termes cet
analyste américain un nazi tout ça ne
fait absolument aucun sens mais c'est
vraiment le but c'est quelque part c'est
de terroriser le sou téléspectateurs
pour qu'il ait cette image de l'ennemi
et je tiens aussi quand même préciser au
passage que lorsqu il affirme que france
24 a publié ce reportage sur les
mercenaires étrangers qui doutent de
leurs de leurs buts parce qu'ils ne
veulent absolument rien au combat c'est
faux